it's got uh much louder and busier here
than when i last spoke to you quite a
big crowd has grown outside the
convention center in philadelphia where
that count is taking place at the moment
for those
all important final ballots that will
make such a significant
decision for this country now
this side of the street outside the
convention center are people who
are here uh protesting for every vote to
be counted they are
democratic supporters on the whole
people here who feel that donald trump
is trying to somehow
walk the election with his legal
challenges to
stop postal votes being counted so
there's
that noise on one side and then here
donald trump supporters have gathered on
the other side and there's a long line
of police officers
which guy might be able to show you with
their bikes
they're separating the two so there's a
slight standoff between these two crowds
of people
and the police here are here to separate
them there is a heavy police presence
and i've seen members of the military
outside the city hall here as well
let me just introduce you to someone who
might be able to give us an idea of how
they're feeling today this is walt
walt hello thank you for speaking to us
now obviously you're here as a donald
trump supporter i see
absolutely how are you feeling today
well i'm feeling really sad for our
country
because uh this is not a fair election
any
american any person on the planet with a
thinking brain
understands what's happening right
before our eyes
before they stop counting donald trump
was ahead in all these key states
all of a sudden they decided to stop
counting then when they knew how many
ballots they needed
to over pass him
they came up with mysterious votes 20 30
000 100 for biden america
is a great country americans are only
going to stand for this so much longer
before something horrible happens the
democratic party is not the party of
john f kennedy
they are socialists they know that you
can't get power unless they cheat and
steal
what's going on in this building behind
us is raw
corruption at its finest can i just can
i just put it to you
when you frame it like that of course it
sounds unfair
but the reality is that postal balance
male imbalance
were counted afterwards and more
democrats spoke by males so why is that
if you don't think that male and ballots
are
right for corruption they are not
requiring people to have put their
signature
they're not just if you look at the fact
that right in this building
they're not allowing poll watchers
they're not allowing them they're
putting paper on the window
that says we are doing something wrong
and it's right on display you don't have
to be a genius
understand if they let poll watchers in
it's a different story corruption is
going on
[Music]
in this country would it make you feel
better if i said to you that
i was there in detroit and i met
republican poll watchers
in the counting rooms they were there
would that make you feel better if you
were reassured of the fact
we allow observers they think observers
should be
100 yards away so you can look in the
building
you're not observing a political
election if you're
15 20 feet from what they're doing they
are hiding
when you hide something as a human being
that means you're doing something wrong
okay one last question if you could be
reassured
of the fairness of this election and the
courts
were to reassure you that this has been
a fair election there hasn't been
widespread
can you find it in yourself to accept
the results and move on
absolutely we live in a democracy but
the key fact is
there is corruption going on here there
is
so if we were guaranteed it was fair
i don't know how you're going to do that
with what's going on because
everything they're doing says we are
hiding something
we're doing something wrong i don't know
how you tell americans
all of a sudden that what's going on
behind closed doors is fair
okay well thanks for speaking to me um
you know
as you've heard there from walt there's
immense passion on both sides here
it's hard to see how after this election
that will change trump's supporters
believe every word he says they adore
him and he is
continuing to peddle this narrative that
this election has been stolen from him
it has been cheated somehow there's no
evidence to support that
but it is really adding to the
challenges here in this country with
this democratic process that is still in
action right now